alors qu'un million trois cent mille
foyers je vous le disais restent privés
d'électricité dans l'est le centre
l'ouest et le sud ouest le bilan des
deux tempêtes qui ont frappé la france
s'est encore alourdi 74 personnes ont
péri ces trois derniers jours jacques
chirac se rendra dans la haute vienne
demain auprès des populations sinistrées
l'état de catastrophe naturelle a été
déclaré aujourd'hui pour une soixantaine
de départements
le point avec sophie rolland un
gigantesque meccano aérien dans le ciel
de l'alsace c'est hélicoptère est venue
de pau pour changer un pylône d'une
ligne haute tension
une mobilisation à l'image de ce qu'ils
se fassent un peu partout en france une
mobilisation qui a payé près de six cent
mille foyers ont retrouvé la lumière
aujourd'hui mais un million trois cent
mille ans sont toujours privés ce soir
notamment dans le sud-ouest le centre et
l'ouest selon jean pierre chevènement
retour à la normale s'annonce difficile
avant la fin de la semaine
il est probable qu'il y aura encore des
zones d'ombré les autres resteront
plongée dans l'obscurité parce que le
raccordement au réseau électrique n'aura
pas pu être fait
quelles proportions je ne peux pas le
dire conséquence des coupures
d'électricité et un million d'abonnés
sont toujours privés de téléphone
la situation pourrait même se dégrader
dès demain dans les petites villes et
les zones isolées du sud de la france
là les abonnés dépendent de petits
centraux relayé par de simples batterie
qui ont une autonomie limitée ces petits
centraux sont sécurisés par des
batteries comme ça des grosses batteries
qui leur donne une autonomie de environ
deux jours
malheureusement si le courant électrique
ne revient pas à vous deux jours ces
batteries sont vides le central s'arrête
qui peut expliquer que une zone qui
étaient en bon fonctionnement d'un seul
coup devient cette fois-ci hors service
autre problème la pénurie d'eau potable
faute d'électricité pour actionner les
pompes les châteaux d'eau vides ne
peuvent renouveler leur stock principale
région touchée l'aquitaine le limousin
et le poitou charentes
conséquence certains préfets ont décidé
de rationner l'eau minérale
les distributeurs d'eau et mobilisent
leurs groupes électrogènes
actuellement nous essayons d'acheminer
des groupes électrogènes vers la
dordogne et vers le sud de la gironde à
partir d'autres régions où le manque
d'eau
n'est pas du tout une réalité outre le
manque d'eau potable certaines régions
doivent faire face à d'importantes
inondations notamment dans l'ouest de la
france et ce soir les niveaux de la
sarthe et de la loire ne cesse
d'augmenter